you guys went through a lot with your
family with Noah and understanding the
importance of health and family and all
of that so I imagine having that around
you is is a lot right now the truth is
that this truly had an impact when we
started to think about families who were
going through tough stuff like we were
and there was a point with Noah when his
counts were low and we really had to be
really careful about viruses and things
because his immune system was really
weak and I think when my wife and I
really started to think about not just
kids but adults mothers brothers you
know a lot of people going through
really hard enough things and then
adding that on top I think it really
affected us and I think that we
understood how desperate how panicked
how scary this is you know I've been off
the social media since my boy was
diagnosed I never never went back and I
felt like for me social media had become
something that wasn't great for my
mental health and I thought like it was
sometimes it was really nice assisting
and I would see things and I just got
just for me got really tiresome to see
people taking selfies and showing
pictures of their fancy life and their
food and and you know showing off their
lives in this way that wasn't really
unrealistic and I could see it putting
pressure on everyday people that wanted
to live this way but their goal was
impossible and so I thought I'd never
come back to it but this for me this and
what we're doing even now you and I this
is why it's great this is why social
media can work because you know what it
could be a great voice we need people
that we enjoy watching and that you know
we enjoy your music and just who you are
as a person so to see you guys
which it's just comforting in a strange
way it's lovely you know well you know I
think we both felt it was almost part
and parcel but if we were gonna ask
people to stay home to not leave and to
stay in their apartment of the state in
their house or their condo or whatever
it was we felt like we better be
part of giving people something to do
while they're there maybe we can
actually talk to people about mental
health
maybe we can and so what we did is
actually came up with an idea that on
Mondays I can't remember the exact
schedule but it's like we have one day
where we do some exercise you don't need
that equipment like people like me
little fat dudes can you know give in
the living room and have have their wife
train them and just like my so my wife
will go through simple things you don't
need equipment for on Tuesdays I think
we cook and we do simple things that
everyone would kind of have in their
kitchen at this point I think one day
Wednesday's I think that might be wrong
with all this but Wednesday's I think we
talked about maybe our favorite TV shows
you know YouTube rabbit hole things like
that podcast and then Thursday I think
we're gonna play games and do maybe like
karaoke stuff and talk with people and
and then Friday we'll do q and A's and
just talk you know it's really hard for
us is the homeschooling oh my god I am
so many things I'm good at a lot of
things and that is not one of them it's
really really tough are you good at
teaching the math are you the English or
are you more of the music to eat no
there's that's funny I this morning I
was I had a lie he's four and my wife
had Noah and he's six and she was
reading books with Noah and doing some
math and for me I had sort of Eli doing
simple things like you know I have
pictures drawn of the biggest to
smallest okay you tell me what he's
Furcal the smallest and simple things
like that and then I got to his name and
I said okay we're gonna write your name
Elias and now I want you to write it and
he looked at me and said no I'm not
doing that this is this is no fun he
said I want to go I want my iPad I said
you're not giving your iPad and then it
just became an explosion is trying to
cutting the kids hair herself
Jackson's hair is getting so long how is
that going and she
I don't listen I know that was me that
you're gonna go and do it maybe I could
be there
so long story short she cut her bangs
and then
they put them in ponytails and I was
wrong okay I admit it as usual
I was wrong it is so cute and what's
scary is that she looks exactly like my
wife I mean they are little twins and
now I'm so happy she did it but I wanted
to be involved in that because you know
it's funny I said to her maybe I'll cut
no one Eli's hair they're getting wrong
and she said no no I just don't get
where this inequality comes from